two cars collide fighting for the first  lap position  here comes the leader he dives into the  stern  [Music]  i'm dylan hart jr and i'm on a journey  a journey to find and explore  old abandoned race tracks a journey  that retraces the footsteps of my heroes  and immortalizes their greatness green  flag is waiting  at the very places in which they excel  down the beach full throttle  accelerating sliding shifting in split  seconds  a journey that seeks closure for anyone  forced  to cope with the grief of losing their  beloved speedway  i've learned everything about life right  here on this asphalt  a journey that when it started  i had no idea one of those people would  be  me that's crazy  you